allez on va cueillir donc celle qui à
choisir agathe c'était deborah alors on
se rappelle elle avait elle avait parlé
de son guide
or au regard des et juste après être
avez vous avez dit que vous aviez un
rang 1 un guide qui s'appelle roro et ça
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter si
damas dément bien sûr que je suis là et
bien bien monde kitano n'a alors lui
gelé dans le collimateur parce que ces
derniers temps bale en a fait chez
certains moi je peux te dire une chose
c'est que il va il va pas tarder à se
prendre à une petite preuve dans la tête
mais le sait déjà une septième à devoir
payer
il sait qu'il va devoir payer mais il a
déjà un petit plan calculé pour essayer
de raccourcir les chariots tenchu
maintien tout le monde est déjà je
voulais vous dire bonjour à tous
mais nous devons payer
[Applaudissements]
des voix remercie d'être là et je vous
jure à laillé cette prédiction mais bien
tout de suite après on a eu les
résultats donc du procès ont référé avec
karine ferri je vous rappelle c'était ça
dont il parlait en euros et c'est vrai
qu'elle de vous avez réclamé un million
d'euros et donc ouais ou au lit elle
avait au bois 12000 euros voilà c'est
beaucoup c'est une belle somme quand
même
mais voilà avait réclamé un million
d'euros voilà qui ferait c'est karine
fait rien c'est pas non plus un prix
nobel
karine ferri quoi c'est factuellement
voilà factuellement c'est vrai c'est pas
après nos banon même si tu aime abba ou
non mais je vous dis que je ne critique
pas mais mon karine ferri voilà c'est
pas lui qu'un voilà donc deborah ma
chérie est ce que tu es toujours en
contact les crocs toujours que agathe a
choisi merci déborah est ce que tu peux
nous faire des prédictions sur balances
ton post déjà balance mon poste
reviendra l'année prochaine
donc je suis content tu nous avais
prédit le truc voilà sur le procès va tu
vois c'est arrivé rien et est ce que tu
peux me dire aussi si charme va conclure
[Rires]
haro pas ce que cherche maintenant
charles et moi on est comme ça te dire
là j'ai besoin de savoir où ils vont en
effet senti mentalement à partir de
lundi matin des baux alors je tiens à
dire qu'à la base je suis médium je suis
pas voyante un même sirem et a fait une
belle prédictions tu vois je le dis un
général et se trompe rarement
il est très fort voilà vraiment bravo
alors je sais pas si bon vous avez lu un
petit peu comment ça se passait je suis
pas posséder je vais bien on dirait pas
comme ça mais je tenais à vous remercier
parce que parce que vous avez après
quelques jours après dit que les choses
étaient vraies dans le monde ne l'aurais
pas fait alors on attend alors je vous
dire que je suis con c'est vrai je dis
qu'on sait vous tout le monde ne
l'aurais pas fait ouais bonne réponse à
qui karine ferri
[Rires]
[Musique]
je n'ai pas donc c'est karine verrait
foot hier mais moins cher que le csa
c'est vrai que le caire dans le temps
additionnel alors si cette heure ci a
découché à paris sa séance photo de
demain allez allez donc j'appelle mon
guide
alors où la numéro tenir numérotées le
mien est un numéro azur juillet ce n'est
pas un numéro payant une question amène
à une réponse si quelqu'un une question
alors qu'une émission j'ai une question
sérieuse
est-ce que balances ton post donc sera
là l'année prochaine
est-ce que balances ton post va encore
bien marché l'année prochaine
est-ce que balance ton post va cartonner
encore l'année prochaine on va dire que
c'est pas trop durement fait valoir
pas trop dur c'est ce que me disent
généralement mes ex à l'avenir aussi
alors oui allait appeler mon guide et on
va avoir une petite fallait qu'on
appelle t aime toutes et tous tout
l'hérault
je demande alors si je suis la maison
font bien sûr que je suis là et bien
bien lentement là tu vois je te l'avais
dit tu prendrais une petite prune tu
t'es pris une petite radio qu'à une
chose des sciences et comment si je te
remercie parce que tu a confirmé une
chose est sûre c'est que ton émission
non seulement va cartonner milliers de
nouvelles missions car ils viennent
série qui arrive et il ya quelque chose
d'un projet tu as parlé à personne et
qui m'a pas tarder à sortir en tout cas
se révéler oui ton émission est en
marche et oui elle va se concrétiser
oui tu auras de nouveaux chroniqueurs où
es tu penses déjà et oui ça marche
à remercier les nouvelles émissions
merci rond vas-y vas-y pascal qu'est-ce
que je ne tiens pas encore à garder les
chats je peux te dire une chose c'est
agathe et bien c'est une fille adorable
c'est une fille généreuse c'est une
fille qui à la base de thé vraiment très
réservé très bien trop vertueux et qui a
beaucoup changé qui a beaucoup évolué et
qui beaucoup soutenu fois moins pour ce
qui est du travail
eh bien je marque il ya des choses mais
qui sont entrés duction dont elle ait eu
peu peur elle a un petit peu le trac et
que ça se fera elle va faire une
émission pour elle-même ça va marcher
c'est comment tu m'as tu fais un gars tu
n'aies pas peur ça marchera parce que je
sais que tu aimes bien du moment de ce
très vieux secteur où tu pensais que ça
marcherait pas mais je sais que ça
marchera tu verras tu es tellement de
choses à lui dire mais on n'en parlera
plus tard 0
j'ai deux dernières questions est-ce que
donc charles va pécho bombes allaient
demander est ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent ce qui va conclure moi je dirai
ce que vraiment est ce que vraiment il
va aller jusque dans le lit c'est bien
je sais que ça va être compliqué je sais
que ça va être difficile et je sais que
ça va partir très vite mais je tique et
leur entraînement à lui tout seul
évidemment quand ça marchera
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
confiance est en train de s que doc
gynéco va se réveiller
je pense qu'ils y aient pas vraiment
bien et va si bien
[Applaudissements]